x-ray tell us the tower wind two zero
zero two zero two six runway one eight
left click the option
one eight left clear option three one
four at x-ray so you wanna learn how to
fly but why does it seem like you need a
degree in meteorology in order to
understand the forecast that you get as
a pilot
today i just want to tell you that
you're not alone everybody struggles
with taps and metars when they're first
getting started if you plan on being a
pilot you have to know how to decipher
those not only are you required to know
how to do that on your written exam and
your check ride but you're also required
to check the weather anytime you fly in
or out of an airport and tafsam metars
are your official weather products so
let's spend a few minutes today and
learn how to decipher those
the first thing i want to talk about
today are surface observations this is
the current weather that's being
observed from the ground at an airfield
and these fall into two categories
metars and species metar stands for
meteorological aerodrome report and if
you notice i can't pronounce that m word
very well so i'm glad we use this
acronym anyways the word aerodrome there
just means airport or airfield and what
amitar is is a regularly scheduled
weather report that comes out once every
hour especially on the other hand is a
special weather report and this is just
an unscheduled weather report that comes
out between the hourly metars and these
will usually come out when there's bad
weather or rapidly changing weather the
big picture is that they want you to
have the most current weather
observation and metars and species are
how they do that and when you get these
reports this is what they're going to
look like and if you're like me and this
is the first time you've ever seen one
of these this probably looks like a
bunch of chinese to you but don't worry
it's not as hard as you think and i'm
going to explain all of it to you right
now but one thing you should be aware of
first is that the information these
surface observations is always in the
same order and that's going to make it a
little bit easier for us to decipher
these but just keep in mind that not all
this information here is required so you
won't always see significant weather dew
point or remarks let's pull up
aviationweather.gov and take a look at
some of the metars across the country
this first little grouping of letters is
the airport identifier code in the
continental us all the airport
identifier codes start with the letter k
followed by three digits and by using
this code you can easily search for the
weather report you need so now i know
that i'm looking at tulsa
international's meetar right now after
the identifier the very next grouping of
numbers is the date and time that the
observation was made and as you can see
by the z at the end there this date and
time are in zulu the first two numbers
in this grouping represent the day of
the month so we know this observation
was made on the 25th then the next four
digits represent the zulu time it was
made and unfortunately if you want to
know the local time it was made you'll
have to convert from zulu to local time
here in tulsa during daylight savings
time we're plus 5 so i know that this
was made at 8 53 pm here's something
kind of weird that you'll want to know
about if you look at these observations
later in the day if the zulu time you
see here is past midnight that's also
going to roll over your zulu day so in
this example in tulsa oklahoma this
observation was made on the 24th of
march if this whole zulu thing is brand
new to you and you're scratching your
head right now i'll put a link in the
description below of a video i made a
few months back it explains the zulu
conversions in a lot more detail and you
can check that out once this video is
done all right let's go back to the next
line of information on the metar and
this little grouping represents the wind
direction and the speed so it looks like
we've got zero four zero at eleven and
these first three digits here are the
wind direction so we know the wind is
coming from the northeast at 40 degrees
and the wind direction is always where
the wind's coming from the only weirdos
i know that tell you where the wind is
going to is the army and how do they
know where the wind's going sorry i'm
getting distracted these second two
digits are the wind speed and 11 kt
stands for 11 knots now on occasion you
will see the wind speed look like this
with a g in the middle in this example
the winds are 11 knots gusting to 21 and
let me tell you real pilots aren't born
they're made by flying in these type of
conditions the next thing we have here
is a visibility and this sm means
statute miles so in this example the
visibility is 10 statute miles and this
just means that you can see stuff that's
10 statute miles away and for those of
you who didn't know a statute mile is
5280 feet and that's a little bit
different than a nautical mile nautical
miles are one minute of latitude and i
explain that more in another video now
as you may remember from past episodes
visibility is important to us because it
has to be good in order to legally fly
under visual flight rules and how good
the visibility needs to be depends on
the type of airspace that you're in but
in controlled airspace you need ceilings
of at least a thousand feet and the
visibility has to be at least three
miles now we'll talk more about the
ceilings here in just a second but i go
into a lot more detail on the different
types of airspace and the weather you
need on my videos on airspace so if we
go back to the metar and we take a look
at tulsa's visibility are we legal to
fly vfr with 10 statute miles of
visibility and the answer is yes because
as long as we have three statute miles
or better we can fly vfr and that's an
example of a test question that you
might see on your written exam in fact
let's take a look at the actual testing
supplement that you're going to be using
on the written test here at jfk
international the visibility is only a
half statute mile so in this example we
can't fly under visual flight rules and
just so there's no confusion this mdw
which is chicago midway is a little bit
difficult to read this one is one and a
half statute miles and so legally we're
still not vfr sometimes after the
visibility you'll see these two letter
identifiers these let you know that
there's some significant weather that
you need to be aware of and a lot of
times that's what's causing that low
visibility and if we take a look at one
of these little codes these really are
made of two parts the first of which is
either a minus or plus sign and this is
called a qualifier the other is the
actual weather phenomenon that's being
observed on the field the ra here stands
for rain and the qualifier lets us know
how much rain we're actually getting the
minus sign lets us know that the
intensity is very light if there's no
symbol that means it's moderate then if
you see a plus sign whatever it is it
has a heavy intensity so if you ever see
a plus sign that means it's like a
circus fire because it's intense
you're welcome for that one anyways now
we know that the weather they're seeing
at the field is light rain and now let's
take a look at some of the other symbols
that you might see in this section this
chart comes from chapter 13 of the
pilot's handbook of aeronautical
knowledge and if you look over here at
the qualifiers you'll notice that
there's a couple more other than the
plus and minus sign one of the most
common qualifiers is this vc acronym and
that just means in the vicinity and is
commonly used with vcts and as you can
see ts means thunderstorms so if you
were to get this coat that would mean
thunderstorms are in the vicinity but
not necessarily on the airport itself
now a lot of times the code for the
weather phenomenon will be listed by
itself but it's not uncommon for one of
these descriptors to be paired with
precipitation or something that's
obscuring the visibility one example
that's common during the winter time in
snowy areas is blsn
and if we took a look at the qualifier
and the weather phenomenon we'll notice
that it's blowing snow that they're
reporting at that airfield here's one
i've seen before when i was up in alaska
fzfg
and if we take a look down here we'll
see that that's freezing fog now most of
these codes make sense for what they're
reporting ra i can remember that that
means rain but who in the world decided
br should be missed let me give you some
quick memory aids for these hard ones
before we move on if mi doesn't make
sense for shallow think mini instead
bc stands for patches think blotchy
hail is gr which stands for gravel
falling out of the sky and putting a
bunch of dings in my car for mist think
baby rain
baby rain if i hear you singing this in
the airport i'm gonna know you watch
this video then fu stands for fumes were
you getting concerned on that one and
i'm sorry i don't have anything for you
on this one whoever decided spray should
be py is an idiot now sometimes when the
visibility is really low and the airport
has the right equipment you'll see a
weird collection of letters and numbers
like this
and what this is is a different type of
visibility reading called runway visual
range often abbreviated rvr
and basically what this is is a laser
beam that shoots across the runway and
measures the visibility in feet and as
you can imagine this is a lot more
precise way to measure visibility and
you'll be learning a lot more about rvr
when you go for your instrument rating
but i'll at least show you how to
decipher this code and don't worry it's
pretty simple this r04 means that the
measurement was taken on runway 4. then
the second measurement is our rvr in
feet so the rvr in this case is 2200
feet and if there's parallel runways on
the field you might see an r or an l
after the runway number so don't let
that throw you off that's just telling
you specifically what runway that is the
next readings we'll look at are the ones
that tell you the cloud cover and this
is an important one to know how to
decipher because you have to know what
the ceilings are at in order to legally
fly under visual flight rules and the
first step in doing that is determining
what constitutes a ceiling here's a look
at the different types of cloud cover
that you might see on a metar or a
specie now sky clear is pretty obvious
that means there's zero clouds in the
sky and on the weather observation
that'll usually be indicated by an skc
or a clr and if the sky's clear there's
obviously not a ceiling when you see the
word few on a metar that means about 1 8
to 2 8 of the sky is covered with clouds
and anytime you see this this does not
constitute a ceiling sct indicates a
scattered deck and that means that the
sky is somewhere between 3 8 to 4 8
covered i like to think of scattered
skies as half clouds and half sky and
anytime you see this this is also not a
ceiling
next we have the broken cloud deck and
the code for this one is bkn and you'll
see this one anytime the cloud coverage
is between 5 8 to 7 8 and this one's
important to remember for you because
this one does constitute a ceiling and
if the clouds are too low you can't take
off under visual flight rules and we'll
talk more about that here in just a
second but for now let's talk about the
overcast layer and you'll know it's
overcast because of the letters ovc and
when this occurs you know that the sky
is completely covered with clouds and if
that's true then you know that this is
also a ceiling but even with the ceiling
we can still be vfr as long as the
clouds are high enough and if you
remember from earlier we said that in
order to be vfr we need a minimum
ceiling of a thousand feet agl
and a minimum visibility of three
statute miles and if you look back at
the metar you'll notice something weird
in this cloud coverage section so
obviously this is a scattered deck but
there's only three numbers here and
that's totally normal on these you have
to add two zeros to the end of these
numbers in order to get the height of
these clouds and now that we know that
we can determine that this is a
scattered deck at two five thousand feet
agl and anytime you see these cloud
numbers here those numbers are always in
agl so now let me ask you a question am
i vfr here at adams field klit well the
visibility is 10 statute miles so we
know we're good there because we need a
minimum of three statute miles if we
take a look at that cloud deck we can
see that it's broken so that does
constitute a ceiling and now we just add
those two zeros to see that this cloud
layer is at seven thousand feet agl so
yes we are vfr here at adams field what
about this airfield right here i can see
that there's a cloud layer at 700 feet
agl don't forget that a scattered layer
is not a ceiling only broken and
overcast constitutes a ceiling so once
again we're vfr at this airfield as well
just be cautious with all this because
there can be multiple cloud decks
depicted on a metar and while it's good
to know about those few and scattered
layers the ones that constitute a
ceiling are the big ones we're concerned
about next we have the temperature
followed by the dew point if you ever
see this with just one number that's
just the temperature and i went into a
lot of detail on the relationship
between temperature and dew point in the
last lesson so i'm not going to go into
a lot of detail on that today but i just
want to point out the temperature and
the dew point are the same here i bet
we've either got some really low clouds
or it's raining here yep look at this
light rain see this stuff's pretty handy
to know next up we have this a followed
by a four digit number this is the
altimeter setting and i know you're
probably thinking well this is
2998 inches of mercury no you have to
add a period in the middle here and
that'd be crazy if it was though right
and last but not least we have the
remark section of the metar and this is
indicated by the letters rmk i'm not
going to go into detail on all the
remarks you might see on a meetar
because that would take us all day and
it'd be really boring but i am going to
point out a few that i think are
important and maybe one or two that you
might see on the test the first one i
want to point out is this a02 because
it's on a lot of metars and when you see
this code you know this observation was
made with an automated weather station
but with that in mind i know that this
metar was looked over by a human being
before it was pushed out if it wasn't
looked over by a human being and the
report was fully automated you'd see the
word auto at the beginning of the metar
and so that tells me that this
particular metar was made completely by
machines and if you've ever watched
terminator you can see how this could be
a problem or just the fact that machines
break all the time and something that
might alert me that there is a problem
with this metar is a dollar sign at the
end of it and this just indicates that
there's something that needs to be
checked by maintenance on the system so
i just take that metar with a grain of
salt now let me show you one that might
be on the written test because this
one's kind of tricky just like in the
previous sections this ra here stands
for rain and the b stands for began so
they're trying to tell you what time the
rain began and it was 35 minutes past
the hour so if we look over here at what
time the metar was produced we can see
that it has to be before this time
otherwise the observer wouldn't have
known about it so we can deduce that the
rain started at 1835 zulu for the rest
of these remarks i'm going to put a link
in the description for a quick reference
guide from www.weather.gov
i really recommend saving it as a pdf on
your ipad somewhere and for your
dinosaurs out there you can print it out
and put it on your knee board if you
want and as you can see this is a pretty
handy tool if you're trying to get the
skinny on the weather okay so now i want
to take a quick look at what a taff is
taf stands for terminal aerodrome
forecast and anytime you see the word
forecast here you know you're getting
the future weather prediction at an
airfield so if you're trying to get an
idea of what the weather is going to be
at the airfield you're landing at these
are what you want to look at and don't
worry these are really similar to the
metars so this shouldn't take nearly as
long to explain as they did and if you
look at the information that's in a tap
you'll notice that it's basically the
same except there's no temperatures or
altimeter settings and you typically
won't see remarks either and something i
forgot to tell you earlier about the
temperatures on a metar is that they're
always shown in celsius you might as
well just quit using fahrenheit now the
aviation community primarily uses
celsius all right so let's pull up some
real taps from aviationweather.gov
and when you look at these you'll notice
that each individual airport might have
multiple lines the first line you see
here with the airport name is the
overarching forecast that lasts
somewhere between 24 to 30 hours now
most taps only last 24 hours but big
airports like los angeles here have
tafts that last 30 hours because they
have long international flights and
those guys need to know the weather a
lot more in advance alright so let's
zoom in here at the main taft line at
jackson international and take a closer
look and just like on the metar this
first grouping of information is the
date and time this thing was produced
but now right after that we see another
grouping of numbers that represents the
date and time that this taf is valid and
all this is telling us is that this tap
is valid on the 26th day of the month
from 1200 zulu to the 27th day of the
month to 1200 zulu and as you can see
this is a 24 hour taft like i was
talking about earlier and if you take a
quick look down at lax you'll see that
this one's valid from the 26th day of
the month at 1400 zulu to the 27th day
of the month at 1800 zulu and this is
the 30 hour tap i was talking about next
just like the metar we have the wind
speed and direction and sometimes you'll
see this vrb on both taps and metars and
that just means the winds are variable
and that lets you know that it's coming
from all different directions and just
like the mitar you'll see the visibility
notable weather and the cloud conditions
and i just want to point out to you this
baby rain baby rain and in addition to
the important baby rain you might also
see this pea in front of the visibility
and that's just telling you that the
prevailing visibility is expected to be
six statute miles and in plain english
that means that they're expecting it to
be better than six miles so as you
already know the weather can change
quite a bit in a 24-hour period so
because of that one general overarching
taff isn't enough and because of that a
lot of times you'll see these two types
of taft lines in the forecast a from
line like you see here means there's
going to be a pretty significant change
in the weather and that change starts on
the 26th day at 1700 zulu and that's
1700 until further notice not 1700 to
000 from lines last until something else
takes its place and as you can see here
this next from line does take its place
on the 27th day and that just so happens
to be 000 hours and as you can see if
they're not expecting a lot of big
changes in the weather in a 24 hour
period you may only see one or two from
lines but when you see a lot of from
lines like this that means the weather's
changing rapidly and you need to really
pay attention to the time that you're
going to show up at the airfield and
make sure that you're going to be vfr
next we have these becoming lines and
these can be on their own line or they
can be stuck in a from line and i call
these tempo bands because they're very
temporary and once the time is up on
them you go back to reading the from
lines and if we take a closer look at
this tempo band up at memphis you'll
notice that the valid dates and times
are really similar to the overarching
taf alright so this becoming line is
only valid from the 13th day of the
month at 100 zulu to the 13th day of the
month at 1200 zulu so that's only two
hours and once those times are up we
should go back to using the from lines
let's take a quick look at some of the
notable weather on this taft because
this could be a test question on some
taft lines you might see a prob followed
by a number in this example it's telling
you that there's a forty percent chance
of whatever information is coming after
that so in this example on the twelfth
day from twenty hundred to twenty two
hundred zulu there's a forty percent
chance you could see one statute mile
visibility thunderstorms rain and
overcasted 800 with cumulonimbus clouds
and anytime i see ts for thunderstorms
or cb for cumulonimbus those are really
important to me and i really want to pay
attention to those now sometimes you'll
see these tempo lines right here and
these are just telling you that some
really temporary weather is coming
through in this example it looks like
from 1200 zulu to 1400 we're going to
get a half statute mile visibility and
that's because of fog now i don't know
why they put them on the testing
supplement because i hardly ever see
them on real taps but these equal signs
right here just mean that that's the end
of that tap for that airport and now you
know how to read taps and metars and
knowing really is half the battle now do
yourself a favor and continue studying
with this video right here and since you
smashed that like button before you did
i've got something special for you
baby
[Laughter]
[Music]